The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
JOHN TSITSIKLIS:
OK let's start.
So we've had the quiz.
And I guess there's both good
and bad news in it.
Yesterday, as you know,
the bad news.
The average was a little
lower than what
we would have wanted.
On the other hand, the good news
is that the distribution
was nicely spread.
And that's the main purpose of
this quiz is basically for you
to calibrate and see roughly
where you are standing.
The other piece of the good
news is that, as you know,
this quiz doesn't count for very
much in your final grade.
So it's really a matter of
calibration and to get your
mind set appropriately to
prepare for the second quiz,
which counts a lot more.
And it's more substantial.
And we'll make sure that
the second quiz will
have a higher average.
All right.
So let's go to our material.
We're talking now
these days about
continuous random variables.
And I'll remind you what
we discussed last time.
I'll remind you of the concept
of the probability density
function of a single
random variable.
And then we're going to rush
through all the concepts that
we covered for the case of
discrete random variables and
discuss their analogs for
the continuous case.
And talk about notions
such as conditioning
independence and so on.
So the big picture is here.
We have all those concepts that
we developed for the case
of discrete random variables.
And now we will just talk about
their analogs in the
continuous case.
We already discussed this analog
last week, the density
of a single random variable.
Then there are certain concepts
that show up both in
the discrete and the
continuous case.
So we have the cumulative
distribution function, which
is a description of the
probability distribution of a
random variable and which
applies whether you have a
discrete or continuous
random variable.
Then there's the notion
of the expected value.
And in the two cases, the
expected value is calculated
in a slightly different way,
but not very different.
We have sums in one case,
integrals in the other.
And this is the general
pattern that
we're going to have.
Formulas for the discrete case
translate to corresponding
formulas or expressions in
the continuous case.
We generically replace sums by
integrals, and we replace must
functions with density
functions.
Then the new pieces for today
are going to be mostly the
notion of a joint density
function, which is how we
describe the probability
distribution of two random
variables that are somehow
related, in general, and then
the notion of a conditional
density function that tells us
the distribution of one random
variable X when you're told
the value of another random
variable Y. There's another
concept, which is the
conditional PDF given that the
certain event has happened.
This is a concept that's
in some ways simpler.
You've already seen a little
bit of that in last week's
recitation and tutorial.
The idea is that we have a
single random variable.
It's described by a density.
Then you're told that the
certain event has occurred.
Your model changes
the universe that
you are dealing with.
In the new universe, you are
dealing with a new density
function, the one that applies
given the knowledge that we
have that the certain
event has occurred.
All right.
So what exactly did
we say about
continuous random variables?
The first thing is the
definition, that a random
variable is said to be
continuous if we are given a
certain object that we call
the probability density
function and we can calculate
interval probabilities given
this density function.
So the definition is that the
random variable is continuous
if you can calculate
probabilities associated with
that random variable
given that formula.
So this formula tells you that
the probability that your
random variable falls inside
this interval is the area
under the density curve.
OK.
There's a few properties
that a density
function must satisfy.
Since we're talking about
probabilities, and
probabilities are non-negative,
we have that the
density function is always
a non-negative function.
The total probability over
the entire real line
must be equal to 1.
So the integral when you
integrate over the entire real
line has to be equal to 1.
That's the second property.
Another property that you get is
that if you let a equal to
b, this integral becomes 0.
And that tells you that the
probability of a single point
in the continuous case
is always equal to 0.
So these are formal
properties.
When you want to think
intuitively, the best way to
think about what the density
function is to think in terms
of little intervals, the
probability that my random
variable falls inside
the little interval.
Well, inside that little
interval, the density function
here is roughly constant.
So that integral becomes the
value of the density times the
length of the interval over
which you are integrating,
which is delta.
And so the density function
basically gives us
probabilities of little events,
of small events.
And the density is to be
interpreted as probability per
unit length at a certain
place in the diagram.
So in that place in the diagram,
the probability per
unit length around this
neighborhood would be the
height of the density function
at that point.
What else?
We have a formula for
calculating expected values of
functions of random variables.
In the discrete case, we had the
formula where here we had
the sum, and instead of the
density, we had the PMF.
The same formula is also valid
in the continuous case.
And it's not too hard to derive,
but we will not do it.
But let's think of the
intuition of what
this formula says.
You're trying to figure out on
the average how much g(X) is
going to be.
And then you reason, and you
say, well, X may turn out to
take a particular value or a
small interval of values.
This is the probability
that X falls
inside the small interval.
And when that happens, g(X)
takes that value.
So this fraction of the time,
you fall in the little
neighborhood of x, and
you get so much.
Then you average over all the
possible x's that can happen.
And that gives you the average
value of the function g(X).
OK.
So this is the easy stuff.
Now let's get to the
new material.
We want to talk about multiple
random variables
simultaneously.
So we want to talk now about two
random variables that are
continuous, and in some sense
that they are jointly
continuous.
And let's see what this means.
The definition is similar to
the definition we had for a
single random variable, where
I take this formula here as
the definition of continuous
random variables.
Two random variables are said to
be jointly continuous if we
can calculate probabilities by
integrating a certain function
that we call the joint
density function
over the set of interest.
So we have our two-dimensional
plane.
This is the x-y plane.
There's a certain event S that
we're interested in.
We want to calculate
the probability.
How do we do that?
We are given this function
f_(X,Y), the joint density.
It's a function of the two
arguments x and y.
So think of that function as
being some kind of surface
that sits on top of the
two-dimensional plane.
The probability of falling
inside the set S, we calculate
it by looking at the volume
under the surface, that volume
that sits on top of S. So the
surface underneath it has a
certain total volume.
What should that total
volume be?
Well, we think of these volumes
as probabilities.
So the total probability
should be equal to 1.
The total volume under this
surface, should be equal to 1.
So that's one property
that we want our
density function to have.
So when you integrate over the
entire space, this is of the
volume under your surface.
That should be equal to 1.
Of course, since we're talking
about probabilities, the joint
density should be a non-negative
function.
So think of the situation
as having one pound of
probability that's spread
all over your space.
And the height of this joint
density function basically
tells you how much probability
tends to be accumulated in
certain regions of space
as opposed to other
parts of the space.
So wherever the density is big,
that means that this is
an area of the two-dimensional
plane that's
more likely to occur.
Where the density is small, that
means that those x-y's
are less likely to occur.
You have already seen
one example
of continuous densities.
That was the example we had in
the very beginning of the
class with a uniform
distribution on the unit square.
That was a special
case of a density
function that was constant.
So all places in the unit square
were roughly equally
likely as any other places.
But in other models, some parts
of the space may be more
likely than others.
And we describe those relative
likelihoods using
this density function.
So if somebody gives us the
density function, this
determines for us probabilities
of all the
subsets of the two-dimensional
plane.
Now for an intuitive
interpretation, it's good to
think about small events.
So let's take a particular x
here and then x plus delta.
So this is a small interval.
Take another small interval
here that goes from y to y
plus delta.
And let's look at the event that
x falls here and y falls
right there.
What is this event?
Well, this is the event
that will fall
inside this little rectangle.
Using this rule for calculating
probabilities,
what is the probability of that
rectangle going to be?
Well, it should be the integral
of the density over
this rectangle.
Or it's the volume under the
surface that sits on top of
that rectangle.
Now, if the rectangle is very
small, the joint density is
not going to change very much
in that neighborhood.
So we can treat it
as a constant.
So the volume is going to
be the height times
the area of the base.
The height at that point is
whatever the function happens
to be around that point.
And the area of the base
is delta squared.
So this is the intuitive way
to understand what a joint
density function really
tells you.
It specifies for you
probabilities of little
squares, of little rectangles.
And it allows you to think of
the joint density function as
probability per unit area.
So these are the units of the
density, its probability per
unit area in the neighborhood
of a certain point.
So what do we do with this
density function once we have
it in our hands?
Well, we can use it to calculate
expected values.
Suppose that you have a
function of two random
variables described by
a joint density.
You can find, perhaps, the
distribution of this random
variable and then use the
basic definition of the
expectation.
Or you can calculate
expectations directly, using
the distribution of the original
random variables.
This is a formula that's again
identical to the formula that
we had for the discrete case.
In the discrete case,
we had a double sum
here, and we had PMFs.
So the intuition behind this
formula is the same that one
had for the discrete case.
It's just that the mechanics
are different.
Then something that we did in
the discrete case was to find
a way to go from the joint
density of the two random
variables taken together to the
density of just one of the
random variables.
So we had a formula for
the discrete case.
Let's see how things are
going to work out in
the continuous case.
So in the continuous
case, we have here
our two random variables.
And we have a density
for them.
And let's say that we want to
calculate the probability that
x falls inside this interval.
So we're looking at the
probability that our random
variable X falls in the interval
from little x to x
plus delta.
Now, by the properties that we
already have for interpreting
the density function of a single
random variable, the
probability of a little interval
is approximately the
density of that single random
variable times delta.
And now we want to find a
formula for this marginal
density in terms of
the joint density.
OK.
So this is the probability
that x
falls inside this interval.
In terms of the two-dimensional
plane, this is
the probability that (x,y)
falls inside this strip.
So to find that probability,
we need to calculate the
probability that (x,y) falls in
here, which is going to be
the double integral over the
interval over this strip, of
the joint density.
And what are we integrating
over?
y goes from minus infinity
to plus infinity.
And the dummy variable x goes
from little x to x plus delta.
So to integrate over this strip,
what we do is for any
given y, we integrate
in this dimension.
This is the x integral.
And then we integrate over
the y dimension.
Now what is this
inner integral?
Because x only varies very
little, this is approximately
constant in that range.
So the integral with
respect to x just
becomes delta times f(x,y).
And then we've got our dy.
So this is what the inner
integral will evaluate to.
We are integrating over
the little interval.
So we're keeping y fixed.
Integrating over here, we take
the value of the density times
how much we're integrating
over.
And we get this formula.
OK.
Now, this expression must be
equal to that expression.
So if we cancel the deltas, we
see that the marginal density
must be equal to the integral of
the joint density, where we
have integrated out
the value of y.
So this formula should come as
no surprise at this point.
It's exactly the same as the
formula that we had for
discrete random variables.
But now we are replacing the
sum with an integral.
And instead of using the
joint PMF, we are
using the joint PDF.
Then, continuing going down the
list of things we did for
discrete random variables, we
can now introduce a definition
of the notion of independence
of two random variables.
And by analogy with the discrete
case, we define
independence to be the
following condition.
Two random variables are
independent if and only if
their joint density function
factors out as a product of
their marginal densities.
And this property needs to
be true for all x and y.
So this is the formal
definition.
Operationally and intuitively,
what does it mean?
Well, intuitively it means
the same thing as in
the discrete case.
Knowing anything about X
shouldn't tell you anything
about Y. That is, information
about X is not going to change
your beliefs about Y. We are
going to come back to this
statement in a second.
The other thing that it
allows you to do--
I'm not going to derive this--
is it allows you to calculate
probabilities by multiplying
individual probabilities.
So if you ask for the
probability that x falls in a
certain set A and y falls in a
certain set B, then you can
calculate that probability
by multiplying individual
probabilities.
This takes just two lines of
derivation, which I'm not
going to do.
But it comes back to
the usual notion of
independence of events.
Basically, operationally
independence means that you
can multiply probabilities.
So now let's look
at an example.
There's a sort of pretty famous
and classical one.
It goes back a lot more
than a 100 years.
And it's the famous
Needle of Buffon.
Buffon was a French naturalist
who, for some reason, also
decided to play with
probability.
And look at the following
problem.
So you have the two-dimensional
plane.
And on the plane we draw a
bunch of parallel lines.
And those parallel lines are
separated by a length.
And the lines are apart
at distance d.
And we throw a needle at random,
completely at random.
And we'll have to give a meaning
to what "completely at
random" means.
And when we throw a needle,
there's two possibilities.
Either the needle is going to
fall in a way that does not
intersect any of the lines, or
it's going to fall in a way
that it intersects
one of the lines.
We're taking the needle to be
shorter than this distance, so
the needle cannot intersect
two lines simultaneously.
It either intersects 0, or it
intersects one of the lines.
The question is to find the
probability that the needle is
going to intersect a line.
What's the probability
of this?
OK.
We are going to approach this
problem by using our standard
four-step procedure.
Set up your sample space,
describe a probability law on
that sample space, identify
the event of interest, and
then calculate.
These four steps basically
correspond to these three
bullets and then the last
equation down here.
So first thing is to set
up a sample space.
We need some variables to
describe what happened in the
experiment.
So what happens in the
experiment is that the needle
lands somewhere.
And where it lands, we can
describe this by specifying
the location of the center
of the needle.
And what do we mean by the
location of the center?
Well, we can take as our
variable to be the distance
from the center of the needle
to the nearest line.
So it tells us the vertical
distance of the center of the
needle from the nearest line.
The other thing that
matters is the
orientation of the needle.
So we need one more variable,
which we take to be the angle
that the needle is forming
with the lines.
We can put the angle here,
or you can put in there.
Yes, it's still the
same angle.
So we have these two variables
that described what happened
in the experiment.
And we can take our sample space
to be the set of all
possible x's and theta's.
What are the possible x's?
The lines are d apart, so the
nearest line is going to be
anywhere between
0 and d/2 away.
So that tells us what the
possible x's will be.
As for theta, it really
depends how
you define your angle.
We are going to define our theta
to be the acute angle
that's formed between the needle
and a line, if you were
to extend it.
So theta is going to be
something between 0 and pi/2.
So I guess these red pieces
really correspond to the part
of setting up the
sample space.
OK.
So that's part one.
Second part is we
need a model.
OK.
Let's take our model to be that
we basically know nothing
about how the needle falls.
It can fall in any possible way,
and all possible ways are
equally likely.
Now, if you have those parallel
lines, and you close
your eyes completely and throw a
needle completely at random,
any x should be equally
likely.
So we describe that situation by
saying that X should have a
uniform distribution.
That is, it should have a
constant density over the
range of interest.
Similarly, if you kind of spin
your needle completely at
random, any angle should be as
likely as any other angle.
And we decide to model this
situation by saying that theta
also has a uniform
distribution over
the range of interest.
And finally, where we put it
should have nothing to do with
how much we rotate it.
And we capture this
mathematically by saying that
X is going to be independent
of theta.
Now, this is going
to be our model.
I'm not deriving the model
from anything.
I'm only saying that this sounds
like a model that does
not assume any knowledge or
preference for certain values
of x rather than other
values of theta.
In the absence of any other
particular information you
might have in your hands, that's
the most reasonable
model to come up with.
So you model the problem
that way.
So what's the formula for
the joint density?
It's going to be the
product of the
densities of X and Theta.
Why is it the product?
This is because we assumed
independence.
And the density of X, since
it's uniform, and since it
needs to integrate to 1, that
density needs to be 2/d.
That's the density of X.
And the density of
Theta needs to be 2/pi.
That's the value for the density
of Theta so that the
overall probability over this
interval ends up being 1.
So now we do have our joint
density in our hands.
The next thing to do
is to identify
the event of interest.
And this is best done
in a picture.
And there's two possible
situations
that one could have.
Either the needle falls this
way, or it falls this way.
So how can we tell if one or the
other is going to happen?
It has to do with whether this
interval here is smaller than
that or bigger than that.
So we are comparing
the height of this
interval to that interval.
This interval here
is capital X.
This interval here,
what is it?
This is half of the length of
the needle, which is l/2.
To find this height, we take l/2
and multiply it with the
sine of the angle
that we have.
So the length of this
interval up here is
l/2 times sine theta.
If this is smaller than
x, the needle does not
intersect the line.
If this is bigger than
x, then the needle
intersects the line.
So the event of interest, that
the needle intersects the
line, is described this way
in terms of x and theta.
And now that we have the event
of interest described
mathematically, all that we
need to do is to find the
probability of this event, we
integrate the joint density
over the part of (x, theta)
space in which this
inequality is true.
So it's a double integral over
the set of all x's and theta's
where this is true.
The way to do this integral is
we fix theta, and we integrate
for x's that go from 0
up to that number.
And theta can be anything
between 0 and pi/2.
So the integral over this set
is basically this double
integral here.
We already have a formula
for the joint density.
It's 4 over pi d, so
we put it here.
And now, fortunately,
this is a pretty
easy integral to evaluate.
The integral with respect to x
-- there's nothing in here.
So the integral is just the
length of the interval over
which we're integrating.
It's l/2 sine theta.
And then we need to integrate
this with respect to theta.
We know that the integral of a
sine is a negative cosine.
You plug in the values for
the negative cosine
at the two end points.
I'm sure you can do
this integral .
And we finally obtain the
answer, which is amazingly
simple for such a pretty
complicated-looking problem.
It's 2l over pi d.
So some people a long, long time
ago, after they looked at
this answer, they said that
maybe that gives us an
interesting way where one could
estimate the value by
pi, for example,
experimentally.
How do you do that?
Fix l and d, the dimensions
of the problem.
Throw a million needles on
your piece of paper.
See how often your needless
do intersect the line.
That gives you a number
for this quantity.
You know l and d, so you can
use that to infer pi.
And there's an apocryphal story
about a wounded soldier
in a hospital after the
American Civil War who
actually had heard about this
and was spending his time in
the hospital throwing needles
on pieces of paper.
I don't know if it's
true or not.
But let's do something
similar here.
So let's look at this diagram.
We fix the dimensions.
This is supposed to
be our little d.
That's supposed to
be our little l.
We have the formula from the
previous slide that p
is 2l over pi d.
In this instance, we choose
d to be twice l.
So this number is 1/pi.
So the probability that the
needle hits the line is 1/pi.
So I need needles that are
3.1 centimeters long.
I couldn't find such needles.
But I could find paper clips
that are 3.1 centimeters long.
So let's start throwing paper
clips at random and see how
many of them will end up
intersecting the lines.
Good.
OK.
So out of eight paper clips,
we have exactly four that
intersected the line.
So our estimate for the
probability of intersecting
the line is 1/2, which gives us
an estimate for the value
of pi, which is two.
Well, I mean, within an
engineering approximation,
we're in the right
ballpark, right?
So this might look like a
silly way of trying to
estimate pi.
And it probably is.
On the other hand, this kind of
methodology is being used
especially by physicists and
also by statisticians.
It's used a lot.
When is it used?
If you have an integral to
calculate, such as this
integral, but you're not lucky,
and your functions are
not so simple where you can do
your calculations by hand, and
maybe the dimensions are
larger-- instead of two random
variables you have 100
random variables, so
it's a 100-fold integral--
then there's no way to do
that in the computer.
But the way that you can
actually do it is by
generating random samples of
your random variables, doing
that simulation over and
over many times.
That is, by interpreting an
integral as a probability, you
can use simulation to estimate
that probability.
And that gives you a way of
calculating integrals.
And physicists do actually use
that a lot, as well as
statisticians, computer
scientists, and so on.
It's a so-called Monte
Carlo method
for evaluating integrals.
And it's a basic piece of the
toolbox in science these days.
Finally, the harder concept
of the day is the idea of
conditioning.
And here things become a little
subtle when you deal
with continuous random
variables.
OK.
First, remember again our basic
interpretation of what a
density is.
A density gives us
probabilities of little intervals.
So how should we define
conditional densities?
Conditional densities should
again give us probabilities of
little intervals, but inside a
conditional world where we
have been told something about
the other random variable.
So what we would like to be
true is the following.
We would like to define a
concept of a conditional
density of a random variable X
given the value of another
random variable Y. And it should
behave the following
way, that the conditional
density gives us the
probability of little
intervals--
same as here--
given that we are told
the value of y.
And here's where the
subtleties come.
The main thing to notice is
that here I didn't write
"equal," I wrote "approximately
equal." Why do
we need that?
Well, the thing is that
conditional probabilities are
not defined when you condition
on an event that has 0
probability.
So we need the conditioning
event here to have posed this
probability.
So instead of saying that Y is
exactly equal to little y, we
want to instead say we're in a
new universe where capital Y
is very close to little y.
And then this notion of "very
close" kind of takes the limit
and takes it to be
infinitesimally close.
So this is the way to interpret
conditional
probabilities.
That's what they should mean.
Now, in practice, when you
actually use probability, you
forget about that subtlety.
And you say, well, I've been
told that Y is equal to 1.3.
Give me the conditional
distribution of X. But
formally or rigorously, you
should say I'm being told that
Y is infinitesimally
close to 1.3.
Tell me the distribution of X.
Now, if this is what we want,
what should this quantity be?
It's a conditional probability,
so it should be
the probability of two
things happening--
X being close to little x, Y
being close to little y.
And that's basically given to
us by the joint density
divided by the probability of
the conditioning event, which
has something to do with the
density of Y itself.
And if you do things carefully,
you see that the
only way to satisfy this
relation is to define the
conditional density by this
particular formula.
OK.
Big discussion to come down in
the end to what you should
have probably guessed by now.
We just take any formulas and
expressions from the discrete
case and replace PMFs by PDFs.
So the conditional PDF is
defined by this formula where
here we have joint PDF and
marginal PDF, as opposed to
the discrete case where we
had the joint PMF and
the marginal PMF.
So in some sense, it's just
a syntactic change.
In another sense, it's a little
subtler on how you
actually interpret it.
Speaking about interpretation,
what are some ways of thinking
about the joint density?
Well, the best way to think
about it is that somebody has
fixed little y for you.
So little y is being
fixed here.
And we look at this density
as a function of X.
I've told you what Y is.
Tell me what you know about X.
And you tell me that X has a
certain distribution.
What does that distribution
look like?
It has exactly the same shape
as the joint density.
Remember, we fixed Y. So
this is a constant.
So the only thing that varies
is X. So we get the function
that behaves like the joint
density when you fix y, which
is really you take the joint
density, and you
take a slice of it.
You fix a y, and you see
how it varies with x.
So in that sense, the
conditional PDF is just a
slice of the joint PDF.
But we need to divide by a
certain number, which just
scales it and changes
its shape.
We're coming back to a
picture in a second.
But before going to the picture,
lets go back to the
interpretation of
independence.
If the two random the variables
are independent,
according to our definition in
the previous slide, the joint
density is going to factor
as the product of
the marginal densities.
The density of Y in the
numerator cancels the density
in the denominator.
And we're just left with
the density of X.
So in the case of independence,
what we get is
that the conditional is the
same as the marginal.
And that solidifies our
intuition that in the case of
independence, being told
something about the value of Y
does not change our beliefs
about how X is distributed.
So whatever we expected about X
is going to remain true even
after we are told something
about Y.
So let's look at
some pictures.
Here is what the joint
PDF might look like.
Here we've got our
x and y-axis.
And if you want to calculate the
probability of a certain
event, what you do is you look
at that event and you see how
much of that mass is sitting
on top of that event.
Now let's start slicing.
Let's fix a value of x and look
along that slice where we
obtain this function.
Now what does that slice do?
That slice tells us for that
particular x what the possible
values of y are going to be
and how likely they are.
If we integrate over all
y's, what do we get?
Integrating over all y's just
gives us the marginal density
of X. It's the calculation
that we did here.
By integrating over all y's, we
find the marginal density
of X. So the total area under
that slice gives us the
marginal density of X. And by
looking at the different
slices, we find how likely the
different values of x are
going to be.
How about the conditional?
If we're interested in the
conditional of Y given X, how
would you think about it?
This refers to a universe where
we are told that capital
X takes on a specific value.
So we put ourselves in
the universe where
this line has happened.
There's still possible values
of y that can happen.
And this shape kind of tells us
the relative likelihoods of
the different y's.
And this is indeed going to be
the shape of the conditional
distribution of Y given
that X has occurred.
On the other hand, the
conditional distribution must
add up to 1.
So the total probability over
all of the different y's in
this universe, that
total probability
should be equal to 1.
Here it's not equal to 1.
The total area is the
marginal density.
To make it equal to 1, we need
to divide by the marginal
density, which is basically to
renormalize this shape so that
the total area under that slice,
under that shape, is
equal to 1.
So we start with the joint.
We take the slices.
And then we adjust the slices
so that every slice has an
area underneath equal to 1.
And this gives us
the conditional.
So for example, down here--
you can not even see it
in this diagram--
but after you renormalize it
so that its total area is
equal to 1, you get this sort of
narrow spike that goes up.
And so this is a plot of the
conditional distributions that
you get for the different
values of x.
Given a particular value of x,
you're going to get this
certain conditional
distribution.
So this picture is worth about
as much as anything else in
this particular chapter.
Make sure you kind of understand
exactly all these
pieces of the picture.
And finally, let's go, in the
remaining time, through an
example where we're going to
throw in the bucket all the
concepts and notations that
we have introduced so far.
So the example is as follows.
We start with a stick that
has a certain length.
And we break it a completely
random location.
And--
yes, this 1 should be l.
OK.
So it has length l.
And we're going to break
it at the random place.
And we call that random place
where we break it, we call it
X.
X can be anywhere, uniform
distribution.
So this means that X has a
density that goes from 0 to l.
I guess this capital L is
supposed to be the same as the
lower-case l.
So that's the density of X. And
since the density needs to
integrate to 1, the height of
that density has to be 1/l.
Now, having broken the stick
and given that we are left
with this piece of the stick,
I'm now going to break it
again at a completely random
place, meaning I'm going to
choose a point where I break it
uniformly over the length
of the stick.
What does this mean?
And let's call Y the location
where I break it.
So Y is going to range
between 0 and x.
x is the stick that
I'm left with.
So I'm going to break it
somewhere in between.
So I pick a y between 0 and x.
And of course, x
is less than l.
And I'm going to
break it there.
So y is uniform between
0 and x.
What does that mean, that the
density of y, given that you
have already told me x, ranges
from 0 to little x?
If I told you that the first
break happened at a particular
x, then y can only range
over this interval.
And I'm assuming a uniform
distribution over that interval.
So we have this kind of shape.
And that fixes for
us the height of
the conditional density.
So what's the joint density of
those two random variables?
By the definition of conditional
densities, the
conditional was defined as the
ratio of this divided by that.
So we can find the joint density
by taking the marginal
and then multiplying
by the conditional.
This is the same formula as
in the discrete case.
This is our very familiar
multiplication rule, but
adjusted to the case of
continuous random variables.
So Ps become Fs.
OK.
So we do have a formula
for this.
What is it?
It's 1/l--
that's the density of X --
times 1/x, which is the
conditional density of Y. This
is the formula for the
joint density.
But we must be careful.
This is a formula that's
not valid anywhere.
It's only valid for the x's
and y's that are possible.
And the x's and y's that are
possible are given by these
inequalities.
So x can range from 0 to
l, and y can only be
smaller than x.
So this is the formula
for the density on
this part of our space.
The density is 0
anywhere else.
So what does it look like?
It's basically a 1/x function.
So it's sort of constant
along that dimension.
But as x goes to 0, your
density goes up and
can even blow up.
It sort of looks like a sail
that's raised and somewhat
curved and has a point up
there going to infinity.
So this is the joint density.
Now once you have in your hands
a joint density, then
you can answer in principle
any problem.
It's just a matter of plugging
in and doing computations.
How about calculating something
like a conditional
expectation of Y given
a value of x?
OK.
That's a concept we have
not defined so far.
But how should we define it?
Means the reasonable thing.
We'll define it the same way
as ordinary expectations
except that since we're given
some conditioning information,
we should use the probability
distribution that applies to
that particular situation.
So in a situation where we are
told the value of x, the
distribution that applies is the
conditional distribution
of Y. So it's going to be the
conditional density of Y given
the value of x.
Now, we know what this is.
It's given by 1/x.
So we need to integrate
y times 1/x dy.
And what should we
integrate over?
Well, given the value of x, y
can only range from 0 to x.
So this is what we get.
And you do your integral, and
you get that this is x/2.
Is it a surprise?
It shouldn't be.
This is just the expected value
of Y in a universe where
X has been realized and Y is
given by this distribution.
Y is uniform between 0 and x.
The expected value of Y should
be the midpoint of this
interval, which is x/2.
Now let's do fancier stuff.
Since we have the joint
distribution, we should be
able to calculate
the marginal.
What is the distribution of Y?
After breaking the stick twice,
how big is the little
piece that I'm left with?
How do we find this?
To find the marginal, we just
take the joint and integrate
out the variable that
we don't want.
A particular y can happen
in many ways.
It can happen together
with any x.
So we consider all the possible
x's that can go
together with this y and average
over all those x's.
So we plug in the formula for
the joint density from the
previous slide.
We know that it's 1/lx.
And what's the range
of the x's?
So to find the density of Y for
a particular y up here,
I'm going to integrate
over x's.
The density is 0
here and there.
The density is nonzero
only in this part.
So I need to integrate over x's
going from here to there.
So what's the "here"?
This line goes up at
the slope of 1.
So this is the line
x equals y.
So if I fix y, it means that
my integral starts from a
value of x that is
also equal to y.
So where the integral starts
from is at x equals y.
And it goes all the way until
the end of the length of our
stick, which is l.
So we need to integrate
from little y up to l.
So that's something that
almost always comes up.
It's not enough to have just
this formula for integrating
the joint density.
You need to keep track
of different regions.
And if the joint density is 0
in some regions, then you
exclude those regions from
the range of integration.
So the range of integration is
only over those values where
the particular formula is valid,
the places where the
joint density is nonzero.
All right.
The integral of 1/x dx, that
gives you a logarithm.
So we evaluate this integral,
and we get an
expression of this kind.
So the density of Y has a
somewhat unexpected shape.
So it's a logarithmic
function.
And it goes this way.
It's for y going all
the way to l.
When y is equal to l, the
logarithm of 1 is equal to 0.
But when y approaches 0,
logarithm of something big
blows up, and we get a
shape of this form.
OK.
Finally, we can calculate the
expected value of Y. And we
can do this by using the
definition of the expectation.
So integral of y times
the density of y.
We already found what that
density is, so we
can plug it in here.
And we're integrating over
the range of possible
y's, from 0 to l.
Now this involves the integral
for y log y, which I'm sure
you have encountered in your
calculus classes but maybe do
not remember how to do it.
In any case, you look it
up in some integral
tables or do it by parts.
And you get the final
answer of l/4.
And at this point, you say,
that's a really simple answer.
Shouldn't I have expected
it to be l/4?
I guess, yes.
I mean, when you break it once,
the expected value of
what you are left with is going
to be 1/2 of what you
started with.
When you break it the next time,
the expected length of
what you're left with should be
1/2 of the piece that you
are now breaking.
So each time that you break it
at random, you expected it to
become smaller by
a factor of 1/2.
So if you break it twice, you
are left something that's
expected to be 1/4.
This is reasoning on the
average, which happens to give
you the right answer
in this case.
But again, there's the warning
that reasoning on the average
doesn't always give you
the right answer.
So be careful about doing
arguments of this type.
Very good.
See you on Wednesday.